hello yo manjong formaggio nevere me
seat para ver me man general formaggio
quindi in say hasta manana
LA where my cane Turia Amontillado solo
formaggio charity commented no check our
naked shell economy's al formaggio
[Music]
my name is Beryl
I'm a senior producer at great big story
and over the years I have made a lot of
videos about food and that is for one
simple reason I love it
woo all kind even the foods I don't know
about yet
so I'm making a whole video about one of
my favorite foods cheese there are so
many wonderful types of cheeses in this
world and they're all different
depending on where you are so for this
video I spoke to seven cheese makers in
seven countries to see what cheese was
like around the world I'm making a
cheese board by the way so this is my
cheese episode in making this I decided
a few things number one the cheese
should be surprising ideally something
that you might not have heard about yet
and to know two cheese's should come
from the same country this is an
around-the-world feed
ok let's begin
yeah some surveillance image presidency
rod magnetic makeup yet Nagi a nice
cookie serious red yummy caliber Simona
approached a market for maggiore very
soon as soon as I get up Kasim Razvi
start not soup my name is like oil we
make a range of cheeses our newest
Cornish home has won several awards
including the world's best cheese in
2017
Naza Vamshi Anna Netrebko yes 10 bottom
Pacific not of the Fiesta Kirara kasnia
yes telco Yvonne's near nationally
mera naam Denis Belliveau
yes it should be with a kangaroo
she'll be Saturn neuter he could do the
grantmaker wonderfully I'm Bob Wills I
live in Wisconsin
I make cheese curds they have a squeaky
noises bites Iran China pal Alex on new
hit Jesse ah hakuta a sub-account the
middle part
via mail pass fake opponent certain
period de l'année the milk talk said
jehan cannot leave our song Talia
Hamilton si la différence avec lui
normal kill vfa to Connie
I myself was inspired so I'm also going
to attempt cheese making in this video
my husband is Indian and I have always
wanted to make paneer my mother-in-law
gave me a recipe so we're gonna try ok I
need two things
lemons and hold up that's it
MEP yeah grad I cross very good sorry
good dude could it could be 100 meter to
largest our genomic adversity name a
girl margarita rebecca soni a LARP our
new chromosome of erroneous anchor going
for the Jolly freshly washed
it's too much garage yes on the run
tomorrow no further system none of the
other motor Bionic is put the edge of
each cable which we summed up align the
motor the church in quantitative Pecora
approval Chum no laughter I'm coming
shot on the press all epic orekhova
basicity on mi piace born other our my
analyzer total a few more
Nigel certain cartoon around here Tony's
an a nutritionist honey
Tony's an airbrush me bar a minute it's
always a new to at the very beginning
the process of making cheese is pretty
standard you start by heating milk so
stove on
who's my second cup of milk please don't
burn okay here we go Sivaji metrodorus
ooh let's go see positive often meet an
emphatic holy sh t
should be your dude
lemme hear my letter to Lama Rama went
is did Rima Amita Tonto Lydia mo is Cal
U juiced authentically Joosten senses
erotic in recipient then we put in an
enzyme to make the milk thicken
traditionally it had been a rennet from
the stomach of a cow or calf of all of
our products are vegetarian so we use
microbial enzyme the milk is then
allowed to quite be late and set against
mu she should go Gingka omelet Cristiano
oh sweet oh no chef
yeah second season degree or a soft
Coral Castle Metallica Vera do knowledge
Kiera I need this body in the chattering
process we let all those small pieces of
curd stick together and we create maths
which is committees or a treatise
Adriana forum Pisa cuando me
[Music]
we are then she formaggio hello methanol
foreman aljalja become a father
the process of making donkeys milk
cheese was a little more complicated and
a little bit more vague also the NOC is
looking pretty good
oh no Sammy Allah says a PETA was a stow
nemesi rod Margaret L made a video sent
a Tony canoes Rhoda president a problem
problem Serio tomato aggression a con
named adobo no kazarina well slew Jesus
Granada Mecca latinum dongho tram
process Petra g.o drezna tiny roshaniya
dresnok problema que droga udemy's
racially boy almost all of Abu Jaffa
that I see would Nagi a nice copy toy -
previous sales morally okay lemon juice
in is it curdling budget more lemon
juice I guess yeah aha okay wait it's
definitely working see this whoa I think
I do that
now I need to press this and for all the
other cheeses as well from this point
forward this is where the processes
begin to differ
yet Quincy Jordy Verrill la forma
Tinkham inshallah a cambiar Cambiasso
consistence a cambiar la forma in
recurrent Eid journey la forma será
completamente inverse al del mosque
occurs Eric del Sol our mosque le Claire
to swap beaten in Carmela form
joven de puta madre tuna Galera
Tirra Tirra Bacardi a gamma su casa
and this was the agamous soup he saw a
bocce being terminology Amy shano shano
- glad to grab para de Carter
[Music]
applicants are only medecine Bansal pona
Venkat ha Kuan Street at a mile a curve
an olefin le fromage jill consumer may
up help reveal if cannot risk a dosa
cheese curds are the best on this tray
Taliban naps cotton do the worst effects
added see no one knew she did vadas
charts that a good tune of silence a
bottom should go veg hunger mushi says
check Wednesday button I do Potomac what
the monopoly to Shivan Sonia afla Brian
process we apply a breathable wax
coating to the cheese it allows for
limited moisture loss its then turned
daily in the maturation store for around
16 months until it is ready to be hand
wrapped and sent to the customer I'm
pressing the paneer and it needs maybe
like 30 minutes and then you can cook
with it and eat it with all these other
cheeses we're finally at the big
question that I want to know which is
what do they taste like
[Music]
for macho macho say so support remaining
pop sul picante dokin man jump o samba
SS man John Doe elastomeric Sherpa
tender Olympus tartan Pola lingua
diverse Gustav bestows oh la la voce
fala Mazda see Road Nagaraju Mecca on a
issue sadness nation Vishal you demotion
appoint a Podesta drama the Buddha's
Adam well not so Cornish can tastes very
sweet very savory fruity so I would say
pineapples with nutty notes cheese curds
are kind of warm and fuzzy there there
huh they have a richness to him and then
as you bite through them you get into
the creamy interior and it has a real
nice buttery flavor should be you Oh
Liberty you Sunda heretic a Liberty ou
Aqaba pogrom the street - no sir Hara
Hara G Gulu Gulu
journey Nilda haider al-abadi suit a new
robot habilis - flappity strategy la
cerva degree needle pass a prediction
for March if we take mmm Lolita homo
lumo
sake lees a homeland flow kiss - solid
path me Ponemah você me mata ki Kosaku
Padova she knows the protocol eatin
badges of a door gunner engine Anya
here it is my paneer paneer is a really
light cheese it doesn't melt and it
doesn't have much flavor on its own it's
meant to go with the heavy spice of
Indian cuisine so it picks up a lot of
those flavors really really well that
was my question with all these other
cheese's - how do you eat them I mean
how do you eat cheese with maggots in it
las palmas real pan for my Jamaat or
prosciutto 15 oedema lon
a lot more tissue yeah different face on
Maui yeah mapa me of a song hooks that
we can I'm gonna have a camera SOPA
silicon song would you follow the
technology is nourished as possible yak
to valina Pravda most not neither piece
back we Assam Ginyard Co clearly you sad
about Kamala with a dancer it could do
the gram guru mocha Java system on you
or something
so one day you hello - hello - a walnut
a dealer
the conical coral very continually
Valentino
Nani cozy say no sorry mo PA de Vere
Minos back na manja madonna vita in a
post ome Coco a proba or Dionisio
diatone esto los que decir autumn
aggressive Nicole PETA new yes a red
Capricia very good I think this project
was cool because while cheese can be a
lot of different things seeing them all
together like this makes you realize
that the culture and the tradition
behind cheese making the Hat is pretty
Universal punaluu yeah the important to
stock reason to see with less fists on
Libya yeah yeah LaMontagne el choclo
alkmaar a pre-party a LOF innovation
proto Sardo qualcuno Lyra Pookie
bellissimo
so coca-cola a fun on college for
muhammad pero los amplicon oh shoot oh
yo no naka no suit mean only in AZ
what's the picture is not opposed to the
no step aboard avi and Hafner you've
washed its our carpet as I'm away she
production on yet immersive kami pop
Estonia it's ours Rochester's mr.
mazzani piranha or a honey guru another
gene inter don't come a real of a battle
Ebola she ride aboard a I'm racing io
Wisconsin makes the best cheese there's
no question about it she's making has
that instant gratification I feel good
about what it does for the people who
are eating it 31 years I'm still eating
all the cheese curds Cornish Kona is
very much unique to our country in our
culture and we think it's important that
we share Cornish can with as many people
around the world as possible so in some
ways cheese is a great equalizer
[Music]
you
[Music]